tanya is with us in Columbus Ohio hey
Tanya
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you for taking my call
sure what's up well one I dated my
husband's back when I was 16 and he was
18 and then we were apart for a long
time then he finally got married well
one of the personality traits that I
fell in love with and I so loved well
until recently is his generosity and his
willingness to help anyone at anytime
he's the guy that pulls over on the
highway to help the person change the
tire oh look celebrated nine years in
May okay the problem that I'm having is
I can't I fell into the trap of saying
well Dave Ramsey said Dave Ramsey said
so now I'm not allowed to say your name
so now I call you Voldemort don't work
these because he says you know your name
isn't allowed in the house so I pull the
whole Harry Potter geek out and call you
Voldemort and I do that whenever because
he's a big business guy or at least the
business mind so he'll say some you know
financial advice and I said hey you know
vuelven wants us the exact same thing
whole month yep he says that to you and
trying to get how can I help you today
well he serve people so much but he does
it against our budget so so so he has an
integrity problem then because his
arrogance allows him to serve someone
outside of his home by breaking his word
to his wife so I guess my name is still
going to be a cuss word there because
hit the first place he ought to keep his
word is
at home before he worries about feeding
changing somebody's tire on the side of
the road that he doesn't know the Bible
says take care of your own household
first or you're worse than an unbeliever
so I think there's a whole lot more
going on in this conversation the way
you're describing my name becoming a
custom word and the way you're
describing him then meets the eye
I suspect the two of you probably should
go to a good marriage conference or two
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]